what is going on guys
welcome to the final part of our
directional movement
system tutorial video in this video we
are going to uh
you know get our true answer to whether
or not we did this
right moment of truth coming right up uh
so i'm going to assume most of you guys
did indeed
follow from the last video i don't know
how you'd be doing any of this if you
hadn't
but just in case i guess you could just
get the script here starting point dot
pi
it's the empty code paste that into here
and between these lines is where we add
all of our new code
so now uh we come to what we have
just built up uh which is here
and let me see here so let me fit this
one to screen where i just pasted all
this stuff
in and this is the code that we
just built so in theory all we really
need to do is we already have
exponential moving average defined so
i'm just going to
delete that from here you might want to
keep it on hand if
you want to save each individual script
um
because what you can eventually start to
do is
uh when i'm done with all of this i'll
probably add them all into my charting
application
and allow users to choose like the
indicators that they want
so eventually i mean you want to have
all this stuff on hand and you could
leave it in this file
and then you could just import every
single file
and do that but again you would already
have exponential moving average defined
so there wouldn't
really be a need for this or for that
rather
but anyways so we want everything here
we already get the stock data so we
don't need to copy and paste that but we
do need tr
literally all the way down to where we
print out adx
and we actually even have to call adx
but we'll get there
so copy all that and we'll have to align
it keep that in mind
paste it all and we can see it really
looks like we need to at least
get a couple tabs over let's see how how
we uh
do keep scrolling here we go okay so
really we have to do
one two tabs uh to be all set
looks like so adx
don't forget we have to actually call
adx and you'll have to call it in the
same alignment as
like right here right so come down
delete
call adx to make sure it runs now we
actually want to go ahead and plot this
stuff
up a good thing to do um that i thought
about
i should have done in the last few
videos is at least for me whenever i
chart stuff in python if i start
charting and then hit an error
my computer gets very angry with me and
throws nasty little errors
so instead i'll just encase everything
in a try and accept loop
that way if we do have an exception
it'll still chart it and python and my
computer won't get angry at me
so i'm just going to do this but within
this try
all we really need to do at least at
this time we have to we're plotting
three different lines right
so we do ax2.plot and then what do we
want to plot
well um
let's actually um
let's see hold on let me think for a
second so within actually what we can do
is let's take this
and put this within the uh
there so this is within the adx function
so we try and we hit 80x here
okay we printed out adx and now let's go
ahead
and we're going to say um the plot date
equals date one colon
uh and then
i think we're ready at this point so now
plot and we're going to plot
date and again so all of the data lines
up we'll do minus
sp colon then we also want to plot 80 x
minus sp colon finally we're going to
plot that line
a lot of times you'll see it black if
the background of the chart
is white in our case the background of
our chart is
it's not black i don't think it's a very
dark color though it's a dark blue i
want to say
so we'll apply the adx line as a w for
white
then ax2 dot plot
and again we want to do uh this plot
date and again we want to do minus sp
colon but this line is going to be the
positive d i line but again
this is going to be minus sp colon and
since it's the
positive d i line we're going to make
this line
g for green finally x2 dot plot
you want to do a plot date
minus sp colon
negative d i
minus sp colon finally this one is going
to be red
that'll be pretty true on every chart
for the most part most people plot that
this line is green this line is red
now let's just add the label plot y
label is
80x 14
color equals w so again like later on
you could have this
all in its own little function um or its
own little script
import that script and then you could
really just have these things as either
top indicators or bottom indicators or
like on chart indicators right so some
of the things like bollinger bands or
whatever
you're gonna have those like on the
chart and then so like this would be a
bottom indicator for example an ax0
which was where
rsi is will be top indicator and so on
but anyway more on that later i'll
probably cover the tutorial of doing all
that
uh when we're all done here and have
like just this massive amount of
indicators that we can choose from save
it
let's go ahead and run it see if we got
any errors uh
we'll do we'll do ebay
again that was a decent one i think
um looks good to me we did print out
everything a little silence those
printouts
but the chart itself looks good let's
fit it to screen here
um so anyway yeah looks good
uh i think ebay is one of the ones i did
show you guys so
um so everything looks good actually
we've been getting pretty lucky with uh
very few typos and bugs in
my script so we're definitely due for
some massive ones
anyway um so that concludes this video
uh with a directional movement system
um everything covered so far i kind of
like this one the best
not sure i'd actually trade on it or
anything but um
as far as you know all these indication
indicators go this one's probably the
closest to being a legitimate
uh usable indicator in my opinion anyway
uh so that's going to include this adx
tutorial
mini series i suppose within the math
and
indicators large series
hope you guys enjoyed as always thanks
for watching
thanks for the support and subscriptions
and until next time